[Music]
um
[Music]
hello welcome back thank you for
watching can't thank you enough
this episode we got a very special
episode why
because we have none other than reggie
watts
in the bag we also have peruvian tacos
[Music]
in the back and all good things must
come to an end
season finale of tacos contolo season
two
gotta give it a second
in the bag let's start the episode
comedian vocal artist beat boxer and all
around
critical thinker reggie watts in the
building what's up man
hello commander
yeah it's like my like little uh
temporary studio it's cozy
it's approachable it's carpeted which i
love
carpet i love a good carpet i really
like the uh the
the setup you have here in my culture
yeah yeah i was i i had a i had a shirt
that wasn't gonna
clear legal so i remember thinking like
it probably won't
so if it doesn't then i really want to
wear this
blanket that i got from charter airlines
but i was like but i like the toga you
know it's just like kind of an old world
kind of look i think it's kind of fun
you know i wish no it was great it
looks awesome i like the texture i like
the pattern because i was like too lazy
i'm like nah taking off a shirt it takes
a lot too late you're too creative
there's not there's no such thing that
was perfect i'm super hungry what do you
say we dig into these tacos huh stand by
for some taco
hey danny rodriguez owner of pablito's
tacos the quick line to our tacos
is tj style with a peruvian touch what
defines a tj style taco
i think it's a handmade pressed tortilla
you must
have your meat grilled with mesquite and
also that guacamole slab
put on on top of it when you don't see
the lady there like
making the tortilla that i'm like oh man
all right and they got the bag
i'm like man you get that smart final
come on man
that's not that smart but it's final
where's the mic i can't drop it so i
think the peruvian touch in our tacos is
from the meats like our chicharron which
mexicans call carnitas we call it
chicharron we also have the pollo la
brassa taco
which is a peruvian rotisserie chicken
the number one
you know peruvian influenza tacos taco
we flame the meat the tomatoes red
onions with
with soy sauce oyster sauce red wine
vinegar
we flame that on the wok put it on the
taco
it's over done
the number one thing that makes publish
what people are saying is the best taco
in l.a not me
just read about it instagram it yelp it
you'll hear this word crack sauce
can you put it right here no
[Laughter]
so the crack sauce which is kind of it's
a play-off of
every time you go to a peruvian
restaurant they'll give you bread and
this green sauce what happens if we
put that green sauce on everything on
the tacos quesadillas
don't even ask the customer do they want
it give it to them
because i know once they try it ta-da
it's over
always be passionate passion is the
number one thing that i think
the customer feels when you're uh you're
portraying that
my man taco
we got some pablito tacos which is
basically a peruvian type taco
right okay um it's a peruvian take on a
tj style taco okay
oh
really badly cg like floating tacos in
my hands it's just like not matching up
to my moves
like whoa this guy oh why thank you yeah
thank you i'm going to asado first
because yeah i mean you wanna and assad
is a palace
which one steak oh the steak
i heard a cat go like no chill chill
it's not a real please
chill and that should be it should
always be followed by a
metal garbage can lid
yeah oh man that's a good duck style dog
that's sick well if you really want to
hear the dog
okay hold on uh-oh okay
see that takes the the the edge off of
the duck but if i do it like this it's
just donald duck doing an impression of
a dog
yeah but it's so cool though because
i've never heard that before it's like
oh really
it was like donald duck doing an
impression of a dog
yeah well
[Music]
wow here's what i like to do i always
like to take the first bite just to get
like a feel for it
you know the mic check and then we put a
little
let me put yeah of course then we got a
little bit of the monitors going right
here
turn it up right now my goodness
it just reacts with the char of the
steak um so it's a pretty it's a complex
flavor it's like really soothing and
chill then you get the spice could you
throw me those clinics
new clinics guaranteed to pick up and
absorb more than six times its nearest
competitor
i sometimes right now when you like show
me the clinics boxes like sometimes i
like no mexican restaurants by the type
of napkins they offer like if you get
the recycled brown ones that you got to
rip like the
the wingstop place it's like yeah man
yeah
like like i need some absorbency yeah
yeah you need people that understand
their food it has to have a
quality to it that says i care i care
about the quality
of our food and we know how much
absorption is needed
yeah know your absorption rate i want to
put you in the hot seat for a second
sure i tracked down some food hot takes
from some of
our favorite comedians here at first we
feast in tacos contodo
i want to see what your take is on on
these what do you think reggie first one
this is from chelsea pretty it says why
does every online recipe begin with a 40
page essay about someone's husband dog
and kids and a brisk walk they took in
the fall
and how they love the challenge or the
changing of the leaves
and their dog's favorite treat sorry
that's just funny okay give me the
recipe
my scroll finger hurts it's so true
right it's so true
it's like i watch a lot of you know like
videos on like
model airplanes and uh microsoft flight
simulator
car reviews tech reviews and all of the
reviews they're all just like
sometimes emotion isn't something you
feel
but rather something you experience
the new gi gt560
suggests that the narrative
and i'm just like just and i fast
forward it i just fast forward it to
like the end part where they're like
well i like this car like that's that's
what i do with all those videos and this
is exactly
the situation this next one is from ali
wong
vegan brunch
vegan brunch tastes like a bowl of
erasers
i get it i get it there's there's some
great vegan brunches
by the way but i've had those breakfasts
and
yeah i want to open up a vegan
restaurant called air quotes
he's like can i get a beef hamburger and
uh uh some chicken wings
would it say air quotes or would it
would just have two quotations just with
nothing in between
i i would take the artistic route and
just put the like quotes almost like
i'm working air quotes because it just
doesn't matter anymore
or things are always encapsulated by
something
something is now about to become nothing
i just want to say man i'm a big fan of
of of your comedy your music i mean
you're just i'm i mean you're like the
grateful dead of comedy and i say that
because
i mean you're a man who improvises i
mean no two sets are the same i think a
lot of times like why
my particular comedy ended up working
out well is because
it it's constantly shifting between
different things and things don't have
to complete
and i think that resonates with in the
internet mindset because
no one just sits and reads total like i
mean some people do but
people usually don't consume an entire
tea of a piece of media then move to
another piece of media then consume it's
usually
you're there for a little while oh i
need to check on this i went back here
i'm going over here it's so it's a lot
of that so i think that it just kind of
resonated
and it's like you're so like
multi-talented too i've seen you beatbox
which i'm a huge
huge huge fan of beatboxing it's like i
gotta say
boy did i try to beatbox for real and i
could never get it down it's like you
you are a master beatbox like like i put
you up there with like dougie
oh [ __ ] man oh that's huge some people
have these crazy techniques
and my thing is like i always did it
differently you know if it was
because well the one thing i didn't want
to beat box like the fat boys
like the traditional old school you know
you know that type of [ __ ]
yeah right that's our [ __ ] because it
was just spit city spit everywhere
so for me i wanted like quieter things
so i wanted like
wow
so it's quieter smaller more intricate a
little bit
crisper crispier wow and then yeah and
then
like throat sounds yeah it's like uh
i don't know spit out a luger here if i
want to improve my beat boxing game
uh is there a handful of tips you can
give me like walk me through it
you want to be able to like manage time
and you want to be able to have a pocket
because that groove is everything so
[Music]
right
but having that groove is like it it it
basically makes your job so much easier
things will start to slip in and you'll
notice oh i can sneak in a hi-hat there
oh oh oh [ __ ] that that when i was
inhaling i can actually use the inhale
sound to sound like a closing hi-hat
like mine i'm doing like a lip
thing but you can also do
i feel like the beatbox sounds that i
make are the ones that come stock on
like a little piano when you buy it
but that that works man you know that's
what effects pedals are for
can i hear you doing like a little solo
for us here at uh taco sure
mr reggie wow
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
something like that
[Applause]
we did it we tried thanks everybody
we'll see you next time that's great man
reggie watts season finale of tacos
contour thank you so much it is
an honor to have you on the show we'll
see you hopefully on the third season
we're out rock out
dear friends we made it season finale of
tacos contodo
season two this last episode was amazing
i got to make a new friend i got to sit
down with the always funny
mr reggie watts we even got to eat some
delicious tacos from pablitos
i hope you're trying sometime also if
you do make sure you put lots of that
green sauce on it because
man does it slap on behalf of first we
feast on tacos contodo and myself
thank you so much for the support thank
you so much to all the taqueros
thank you so much to all the comedians
and thank you most importantly
for watching hopefully we see you next
season
fingers crossed in spanish your friend
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
you